It is time for Drew's News, your daily good news huddle.
(Drew groans)
And with me (Drew groans),
and with me at the desk is co-captain
of the Drew's News team, Rossi, Ross Mathews.
Huddle.
(audience applauding and cheering)
You're loving a chest bump.
You pull it up well Rossi.
Thank you.
Let's dive in with a juicy question today. Here it is.
Should your co-workers feel like your family?
The advice column at The Cut recently tackled this topic.
They got a letter from someone who works at a nonprofit,
were social functions and a family vibe
are a big part of the company culture.
This person said they don't always want to participate
because their work-life balance gets off,
but they're worried they'll miss a promotion
or an opportunity just because they didn't go
on like drinks and scavenger hunts, all that stuff.
Ross. Thoughts?
Well, I think it depends on the job.
I mean, here,
you and I are like baked into one little hot pocket.
We are cool glows.
And because we are ourselves here we share.
But I remember when I worked at McDonald's and yes,
I was a triple threat.
I did the drive through, the register and the grill.
That means I was like the Beyonce of McDonald's.
(Drew laughing)
I was, I was not like I, I have to admit I wasn't all up in
what my co-workers were doing because I don't know.
I just didn't have that connection.
I think it's a really interesting topic.
And the reason I gravitated towards this article is because
I push family culture.
And I think that we spend so much time at work.
So if there's a way to be a human at work
and relate to people and make it personal,
I just think it's a better use of time.
I think so too.
Next if you like to sleep naked as the day you were born,
apparently the writers at Newsweek want you to go for it.
They talked to a bunch of sleep scientists and psychologists
and collected every single reason that you should
sleep stark naked, here are just a few.
Sleeping nude helps you fall asleep faster,
a cooler sleep temperature leads to a deeper
Non-REM sleep for more restorative sleep.
And it can even help with male fertility and vaginal health.
Oh my goodness.
All the sudden we went goop on this time.
I know. Wow
Hey guess what.
(Ross laughing)
Did you hear the news?
Newsweek is real hot to trot on this whole subject Ross.
Thoughts?
I have so many thoughts right now.
(Ross laughing)
I'll, I'll tell you that I don't sleep in the nude.
It's not for me.
Really?
Yeah, no
(Drew laughing) I have
What do you sleep in? Soft Pajamas?
Not Soft Pajamas. No.
I pictured you on Soft Pajamas.
No. Don't picture me at all.
(audience laughing)
I just, you know, it's not for...
I like to be covered head to toe,
but what do you sleep in?
Well, again, it depends on the situation.
If there's no one around,
I am a total nudy.
I love sleeping naked.
I like walk into my kitchen naked.
I love just walk around the house naked.
The house naked?
Yes I do, I do (audience applauding)
We actually open this up to...
it's time for audience poll. (Drew clapping)
That's right.
Okay. If I show of pause,
I want to see.
Are we asking about nudity and polls in the same.
(audience laughing)
Absolutely, okay.
Who's a fan of sleeping "oh ne twa" as they say?
Lot of green, a lot of green, a lot of green, some red.
Okay. We have a Fatima in the audience,
Fatima, why do you like sleeping naked?
Literally every benefit you listed,
I sleep so much better.
I'm more well rested.
And I'm just, I, I toss and turn too much at night
and pajamas are way too restricting.
(pop music)